so the second craziest trump surrogate
lawyer
question mark lynn wood who has uh been
filing all sorts of crazy lawsuits and
is a q anon conspiracy
peddler has been making all kinds of
crazy accusations about john roberts the
chief justice of the supreme court woods
says that roberts knew that scalia was
going to die before he did that
roberts arranged an illegal adoption of
two young children from wales through
jeffrey epstein and then woods questions
whether john roberts skipped a day of
defamation class implying that the
allegations were true therefore not
subject to defamation so the question is
are these allegations subject to
defamation and the answer is
almost certainly yes chief justice
roberts is not going to sue lynnwood he
probably doesn't know who lynn woods is
but these are the kinds of verifiable
provable facts that could definitely
give rise to a defamation claim so if
you found this interesting or
sad check out my other eagle briefs
where i talk about the legal news
i'll see you in court